en todos los vídeos que hemos hecho
acerca de la curva de la demanda hemos
platicado que el precio maneja la
cantidad
el precio maneja la cantidad por ejemplo
vamos a usar esta curva de la demanda
que habla acerca de los coches nuevos
que se venden por día la cantidad de
coches nuevos que se venden por día en
un eje mientras que en el otro eje
tenemos al precio dado en miles de pesos
y lo que nosotros decíamos en todos los
vídeos anteriores es que si nosotros
vendíamos los automóviles a 60 mil pesos
entonces solamente vamos a vender un
automóvil si nosotros vendíamos los
automóviles a 50 mil pesos solamente
íbamos a vender dos automóviles y así
con todos los demás precios porque
realmente lo que nosotros decíamos es
que dado un precio nosotros teníamos una
cantidad de automóviles que íbamos a
vender el precio implica la cantidad de
automóviles ahora lo que quiero ver en
este vídeo es la forma contraria de
pensar pensar que la cantidad implica el
precio y para esto voy a utilizar la
misma curva de demanda la única
diferencia es que lo vamos a pensar de
una manera distinta y para esto lo más
conveniente es pensarlo de la siguiente
manera el lugar
en cuanto vamos a vender una cierta
cantidad de automóviles es más
importante en esta ocasión pensar
cuántos automóviles vamos a hacer por
semana es decir supongamos que hacemos
un automóvil solamente en una semana
ahora la pregunta va a ser en cuanto voy
a vender este automóvil entonces vamos a
suponer que tenemos unos poderes
especiales para leer la mente y que
nosotros producimos este automóvil lo
llevamos a donde lo tengamos que vender
y entonces existe una persona que va a
comprar este automóvil a 60 mil pesos y
es que aquí viene lo de leer la mente
porque tú de una manera extraña sabes
que esta persona quiere comprar este
automóvil que acabas de hacer a 60 mil
pesos no sé por una extraña razón
sabemos o tenemos el presentimiento de
que esa persona quiere pagar está
dispuesta a pagar o tienen la voluntad
de pagar 60 mil pesos por este automóvil
que acabamos de fabricar y es por eso
que podemos poner este punto aquí el
punto 160 mil pesos ahora bien vamos a
analizar qué es lo que pasa si vendemos
más unidades por ejemplo si vendemos dos
automóviles por semana producimos dos
automóviles por semana y lo que sí
sabemos es que
una persona me va a pagar 60 mil pesos
por el primer automóvil que yo fabrique
pero supongamos que no puede pagar la
segunda persona estos 60 mil pesos por
el segundo automóvil ella solamente
puede pagar 50 mil pesos llega la
segunda persona nosotros sabemos
realmente si entonces nos damos cuenta
que esta persona solamente puede pagar
50 mil pesos y por lo tanto tenemos que
dar el mismo precio a los dos clientes
si queremos ser justos cuando los
precios cambian según el cliente lo
veremos en otro vídeo por lo tanto
tendremos que vender cada auto 50 mil
pesos los dos autos los vamos a vender
50 mil pesos y pese a que no se la
vendemos solamente a una persona la cual
podría pagar 60 mil pesos de todas
formas nos conviene ya que vamos a
vender dos unidades por 50 mil pesos es
decir vamos a obtener 100 mil pesos de
la venta de las dos unidades y pues con
la misma lógica va a pasar si nosotros
queremos vender tres automóviles
nosotros producimos tres automóviles y
encontramos una tercera persona
interesada pero esa tercera persona
supongamos no tiene trabajo
ya sabes nosotros podemos leer mente si
no tiene trabajo solamente puede pagar
a mil pesos entonces no va a quedar de
otra más que vender los tres automóviles
a 40 mil pesos ya eso se le conoce como
el nuevo beneficio marginal el nuevo
beneficio marginal va a ser 40 mil pesos
vamos escribir lo que beneficio marginal
que por cierto puede llegar un punto en
donde ese beneficio marginal ya no sea
factible ya no sea costeable porque
puede ser que producir más unidades no
se salga de las posibilidades o nos
salga más caro de lo que de lo que
nosotros lo vendemos y eso se le conoce
como la frontera de posibilidades la fpp
es decir es un conjunto de factores o de
posibilidades en el cual se alcanza la
producción máxima y después de esa
frontera ya no es costeable o ya no
tienes un beneficio cuando producen más
unidades y regresando en la idea del
beneficio marginal
aquí tenemos este beneficio marginal en
términos del precio pero el precio
también lo podemos ver como una
oportunidad fallida esto quiere decir
que si tú gastas 40 mil pesos en este
automóvil no estás gastando sus 40 mil
pesos en otra cosa nosotros
en pagar una casa o en comprar un bote
nuevo o lo que se te pueda ocurrir pero
por lo tanto podemos ver cada uno de
estos puntos como el beneficio marginal
para el siguiente comprador o el
beneficio marginal para el mercado de la
siguiente unidad que vayas a producir y
bueno es que realmente esta es una forma
distinta de ver a la curva de demanda
porque nosotros podemos decir que si
nosotros vendemos los automóviles a 50
mil pesos el beneficio marginal de esos
dos automóviles va a ser aumentar un
automóvil más y que baje el precio hasta
40 mil pesos dicho de otra manera el
precio del beneficio marginal de
aumentar de 2 a 3 consumidores es
bajarle 10.000 pesos es decir de 50 mil
a 40 mil pesos y no sólo eso además
tenemos que convencer a otro consumidor
de comprar el automóvil y bueno yo pues
este vídeo los voy a dejar no sin antes
decirles lo siguiente piénsalo
recapacita lo con tu almohada y fíjate
por ejemplo si nosotros queremos vender
y producir 4 unidades por lo tanto va a
tener que bajar el precio hasta 30 mil
pesos y no hay de otra es por eso que
sería muy bueno que lo analizadas para
entenderle muy bien
lo que sí quiero contarte es que si
nosotros vendemos un automóvil entonces
vamos a tener un cierto beneficio si
nosotros vendemos dos automóviles vamos
tener otro beneficio tal vez lo mejor
que el beneficio sería pero un buen
beneficio en el siguiente vídeo lo que
vamos a ver es que entre más
consumidores tengamos se van a pagar
menores precios o al menos eso es lo que
van a pensar en sus mentes qué es lo que
va a ocurrir